باولا هانوك من سي إن إن هي
مراسلتنا السابقة في القدس وتعرف
المنطقة جيدًا، وهي تنضم إلينا الآن من
سو مع باولا الأحدث، ما الذي
يمكنك أن تخبرنا به أكثر عما
يحدث؟ حسنًا، معلومات إيلا تأتي
إلينا من المسؤولين داخل
مستشفى ألفا الأكبر  مستشفى في
قطاع غزة وفي هذه المرحلة نفهم
أنه وضع كارثي وهذا
أيضًا يأتي منا أه إلينا من
أطباء بلا حدود يقولون أنهم
فقدوا الاتصال بمن
كانوا يتحدثون إليهم داخل المستشفى لكنهم
قالوا كيف
كان الوضع قبل ذلك كارثيا أيضا مع
الإشارة أه أن الأعمال العدائية لم
تتوقف حول مستشفى ألفا نفسه الآن
شيء واحد نركز عليه عن
كثب هو أه بالضبط ما زال
يعمل داخل المستشفى
فهمنا من أه رئيس
سيطرة حماس  دقيقة من وزارة الصحة أن وحدة
العناية المركزة وقسم الأطفال
وأجهزة الأكسجين توقفت عن العمل الآن وقد
أخبرونا أن ثلاثة أطفال حديثي الولادة
فقدوا حياتهم منذ
ليلة الجمعة إلى السبت بسبب
أحد المولدات أه أه التي تعمل على
تشغيل الحاضنات في الأطفال حديثي الولادة
أه تم إخراج القسم عندما
سقطت قذيفة في مكان قريب الآن نفهم أن هناك
36 طفلا حديث الولادة أه ما زالوا في
وضع محفوف بالمخاطر مع عدم
عمل الحاضنات الآن نفهم من المسؤولين
هناك أنهم يحاولون حاليا
إجراء التنفس الاصطناعي أه
لهؤلاء الأطفال  حاول أن تبقيهم على قيد الحياة
وهو ما يعني قيام الأطباء فعليًا
بضخ الأكسجين والهواء يدويًا إلى
رئتيهم، لذا فمن المؤكد أن هذا
وضع يائس للغاية أه مع
هذا الحدث بالذات أه سمعنا الآن
من الجيش الإسرائيلي أنهم
قالوا علنًا أنهم  سيتم
التنسيق لمحاولة إجلاء أه هؤلاء
الأطفال إلى
مكان أكثر أمانًا، نحن نبحث عن توضيح
بشأن ما سيحدث بالضبط،
وتحدثت سي إن إن أيضًا مع صحفي مستقل
داخل هذا المجمع وقال إن
الوضع كان سيئًا للغاية  هناك
نقص في الغذاء والماء والمعدات الطبية
والكهرباء يقول أه
الحصص الغذائية أه ببساطة لا تكفي
وأشار أيضا إلى أن هناك العديد من الجثث
قال العشرات من IES تنتظر
الدفن ولكن ما نفهمه من الموجودين
داخل هذا المجمع هو أن
الوضع  إن الخارج فقط أمر محفوف بالمخاطر للغاية
بالنسبة لهم بحيث لا يتمكنون من محاولة دفن
أولئك الذين يحتاجون إلى ذلك، وكذلك
القدرة على محاولة الإخلاء إلى مكان أكثر
أمانًا الآن، وقد قيل لنا أيضًا
أن العديد من هؤلاء الطاقم الطبي
لديهم  لمحاولة مواصلة العمل
بدون كهرباء وعلى ضوء الشموع
أه لمحاولة إبقاء بعض
مرضاهم على قيد الحياة
أه لا لقد تم إخبارنا أيضًا أن
سيارات الإسعاف غير قادرة على الوصول إلى المناطق التي
يتعين عليهم الوصول إليها لنقل المزيد من
المصابين كما قلت شفاء  هو
أكبر مستشفى في غزة أه بالتأكيد
أحد أهم المستشفيات في مدينة غزة
لذا فإن المستشفيات الأخرى المكتظة بالفعل
تضطر إلى استقبال مرضى إضافيين أه
لا يستطيعون التعامل معهم في
هذه المرحلة، نحن نفهم أن
مستشفى العلي يحاول  لاستقبال
المزيد من المرضى الذين لا يستطيعون الوصول إلى
ألفا، ولا يقتصر الأمر على
المصابين في هذه المرحلة فحسب، آخر رقم
لدينا كان حوالي 400 مريض، وهناك
أيضًا حوالي 20,000 نازح داخليًا
يحتمون في المنطقة
على أمل أن تكون أكثر أمانًا من  مناطق أخرى
ليلى